[Music]
getting right to it the pros of godless
it looked great it really made you feel
like you were inside of this show the
way they shot it
they constantly from scene to scene gave
you a camera point of view shot of the
character was most important the scene
you saw where their angle was coming
from what exactly they were seeing
so really well done at that point the
music was excellent really good western
music here
where they decided to film was beautiful
so many shots just in canyon areas
at the ranch the sandstorm floating in
the sky and shooting through that they
did
spectacular and the sound mixing was
great with the sand with the rain
even the dialogue it was really on point
with all this stuff so
you cannot do any of this better strong
point for me acting wise was actually
the young actors in this show
i think whitey could be a fan favorite
here for sure the actor was really good
the character was great he's so likable
he's very smart for his age well then
truckee alice's son
he was excellent i want to see more of
this kid he was really good actor
and his character was really funny also
really attached to him too and how he
believed in roy good when everyone else
was kind of skeptical of him another
strong character here for me was mary
agnes played by
merritt weaver from the walking dead who
played denise if you notice the face
she was actually one of the few strong
female characters
in the show i'm going to get to that in
a second because i think it's very
interesting how they
promoted the show and what it actually
was but the best part of the series to
me was the villain
and i love a good villain and that would
be frank griffin played by jeff
daniels from my favorite movie ever dumb
and dumber
totally different role here but he was
spectacular as always
every scene he was in he stole every
scene was in general were the best
scenes in the show if he wasn't in a
scene a lot of the scenes in this show
were a chore to get through in a slog
but he
always upped the ante and his dialogue
was great and it really was his acting
just dominated and
i didn't want him to get off the screen
and really liked about this show too is
it
really felt like a classic western the
sense of
if you love that feeling of being in
that western vibe and escapism it really
nails it here and you love horses the
horses here were beautiful and trained
well
i really like the scene where truckee's
learning from roy how to ride the horse
not be afraid of it and fight his fears
it was a drawn out scene but it was
really beautiful and something you would
see in like an oscar award
movie for sure now there's a lot of cons
for me here and i didn't expect this but
to start off
this show is not what you think it would
be it's promoted as a
feminist western that it's going to
change the game of this and it's a
progressive show
and then it's woman empowering but i did
not feel that at all this show to me is
a trick
because if you're selling it on that
point all this story really is is
really roy moore's story versus frank
griffin and they kind of just made this
plot of the town of la belle with all
females
as like a side plot that was just in
there for the sole purpose to say that
this was a progressive western and
it wasn't even the main focus not saying
that it has to be a progressive show to
enjoy but
why put it in then if you're not going
to actually go with it it just didn't
make any sense to the story
where i thought this show was going to
be mainly about the town of lebel
and roy moore maybe would have been the
side character that's how i thought they
were setting it up
but as you go on and on it's really just
your classic western story that we've
seen a hundred times over
where he's teaching a kid of a different
race how to grow up and they're all
learning from each other's culture
and he meets a girl who's just sitting
on the farm and he has a classic villain
it was
nothing new here and that was fletcher
she's pitches the main female lead but
she wasn't good
i didn't care about her and they tried
to give her this backstory that was just
super
all over the place and when you first
hear about it it's a lot of telling and
that's the problem of the show it's so
much telling and not showing
and then when it did show something that
happened you already knew it from a
previous
instance of them talking about it so it
wasn't like shocking it wasn't like whoa
or like didn't give you that
storytelling vibe it just felt like
someone was just
reading backstory off a script so they
could fill in some holes
and she wasn't this like kick butt
female character either sure she's good
at shooting a gun
but that's her whole purpose in this
show i mean literally alice fletcher's
face the whole time in the show was this
the whole time every scene it was just a
one note character
i don't know if that's the actress's
fault or the character's fault but i'm
gonna say both
it was very wooden and no emotion and
there's a lot of loose ends in this plot
a lot of things they teased about they
didn't get to and remember this is a
limited series this isn't
planned for another season the show to
me felt like a show that was setting up
for a season two the whole time
and then they brought in a very bad
finale that just wrapped everything up
in a disappointing way for example so if
they kind of teased what was the purpose
of the one guy that made out of the
mining accident we meet him and he's a
weirdo
did nothing there was no point to his
character introduction at all and then
when a news editor that basically gets
frank griffin to get to labelle and rats
him out
comes back to town no one's mad at him
they kind of just give him dirty looks
but no one actually
tries to fight him or call him out for
what he did and then when he's there
dying he just gets up
no resolution with that and then what
really was ridiculous to me
was when whitey is seeing luis getting
abused by her father
we learn the father is a real jerk he's
really hitting her you can feel whitey's
anger because we're feeling that and
it's adding this meat to a pretty good
relationship that was on the show
and we get nothing from that either the
next time whitey actually talks to the
dad
he comes to town doesn't confront him
about it he's just like hey can you help
us out
like what that's it no mention of him
hitting the girl you love or
any talk of that again so what was the
point of showing us that he was just
like hey man i'm not here to tell you
you want to hear your daughter cool
whatever come help us
just very lazy writing for sure and then
they hype up okay we forget kind of
about blackdom for a bit
we're told they're really good fighters
from frank griffin's right hand and
telling him that and then we see they go
to the town
all this tension at the dinner table and
you're telling me they couldn't get
basically any kills on frank griffin's
people with these trained fighters and
they had the upper hand because those
guys were underground
and they all just get killed immediately
like destroyed and then you compare it
to a bunch of people in lebel
and half them never pick up a gun before
in their life and they destroyed frank
griffin's people so
just doesn't match up well like it's
really asking you to suspend your
disbelief and let me stress i'm not
saying that because they're a woman in
the town they don't expect them to go
with guns
not at all it's they've never had any
conversation that tells us where do they
learn to shoot gun
where do they train are they a renowned
woman with guns you can't just show us
before the big battle
hey here's the gun here's how you load
it oh here's a gun for you here's how
you load it
and then all of a sudden they all have
great shots and you take down what we've
heard is some of the best killers in the
world
i don't get it because the difference of
the black thomas you had that scene
where they explained oh no they have
really good reputation for fighting
and they did nothing and then that
finale what a disappointment in one of
the worst finales i've seen in the show
problem with the show is it was building
up to a big finale it fell into that
trap walking dead's been in for years
relies so much on like teasing this big
end and then you have all these high
expectations and
it does not deliver is the worst feeling
you feel like you've wasted seven hours
of your life i mean frank griffin
who just we've seen obliterate towns in
seconds including blacktime including
the town early in the beginning they
just waltz in
and they look up and then all the town
of the bells in this building shooting
at them
half them never shoot a gun before in
their life they're hitting them sure
you're gonna get some kills because you
have the advantage you have two good
shooters on top that we knew were good
shooters with alice and denise from the
walking dead you tell me
only two of the guys decided to run up
and try to kill them oh and they also
brought their horse for some reason
which is no advantage
in that situation why did they all just
storm that building or better yet
burn that building to the ground like
they did with the other two buildings
they blew up
and no one was in what was the point of
that so they're all just acting really
dumb all of a sudden
and then the shots you're seeing you're
actually seeing frank griffin's people
die really quickly in the beginning but
then more and more
appearing and i thought it was only 30
men so how is there all this men that we
keep seeing shots of
and then when they're getting shot the
problem is when they're showing certain
scenes of lebel people
shooting back and the women are in like
the corners and stuff we don't ever see
what they're shooting at there's points
the way this is edited where it's like
half these people are shooting at
nothing
and some of the deaths were so cheesy
like one of the aimed killers
the guy was on the horse on the top
floor and he had one of those cheesy
deaths or he's like whoa
and he doesn't shoot for some reason and
the girl
shoots him and he just flies out the
window into really bad cgi
on a fire and to say this a female
progressive show is a flat out lie
especially how it ends because then two
guys coming to save the day like any
classic western
and you realize that the main character
roy and the sheriff also
coming to play on both sides they're
really the ones to end frank griffin and
his team
and it didn't get to be alice fletcher
it didn't get to be mary agnes and the
annoying thing was
really mary agnes and alice fletcher had
no connection to frank griffin
whatsoever it was all on roy moore
so they couldn't have that moment anyway
so it was really poorly set up
that's what you're going for and
promoting the show as do it stop
making a lie about it and not choosing
what you want because then it just
becomes a mess and that's what i felt
like it was
like it was being this classroom western
all along but it felt compiled to add
this progressive story
which didn't make sense so go in full
circle or don't or just leave that story
be then and just do a classic question
don't tease with that and i know it
pissed a lot of people off was just
whitey
walking out and being the only one to
really kick the bucket and lebelle
didn't give a chance to shoot his gun
there in that final battle scene he was
such a likeable character so
such an awful death to someone who
deserved a better death if he was going
to be sacrificed he got no killing
didn't get to say goodbye to luis and he
would have been a great character if
they did a season two which are not
going to
and that goes to the whole alice
fletcher truckee because
because it's so ridiculous that roy
moore leaves to see his brother which
okay it's believable
but then you're gonna have the sheriff
come in and now
just basically take care of truckee and
he already has two kids
so how is chucky just okay with this and
i'll switch she's like yeah come back
it's like this quick swap it's just not
realistic and
really corny and again just showing alex
what you're really just like
any female character seen in western
before she couldn't just end up on her
own and raise him and be a strong female
i don't get it the sheriff had to come
in and
be the man and it was weird too how
there's all this thing where alice
brought a bad
curse to the town of the bell but
everyone's so open arms and forgiving of
her when she comes back no one kind of
addresses it and they're all just
fighting together
frank griffin's death was disappointing
because he always said that lion i've
seen how i've died and it's not this
well what was it we never got that
answer he didn't get to explain that or
where he
heard that from what prophet what vision
did he see and then when we saw the
backstory with alice
that she told us about the beginning and
then we see it happen where she got
raped by the buffalo soldiers never see
them again
we don't really know their whole origin
whole story and just got really sloppy
and confusing
about her backstory and maybe the most
awful part of this
last couple episodes was introducing
that random foreign chick
in the shed and she basically kidnaps
that guy who comes in to investigate
and we're supposed to care about them
now and they get more screen time than
whitey in the finale it was like
unbelievable like
what what who are these people you've so
many other characters you've got to deal
with
why are you wasting time on them nothing
felt new here if you're saying a full
town
of females and westerners knew sure
that's true but it felt fake
it wasn't really what this should have
been great idea and it feels wasted now
so thank you for that netflix for the
trick do not be fooled by this
if that's what you're going to see a new
type of westerners really isn't had good
ambitions and good ideas didn't execute
them it's a very very very decent show
and a
super super slow burn especially someone
who loves westerns
and really what pissed me off is when
the sheriff actually runs into frank
griffin and his men
at that little area in the middle of
nowhere and he basically admits to them
that he's been following frank
how in frank's character would he not
kill him right there the sheriff they
just let him go
that made no sense from the way they
handled every other encounter with
someone even if they were slightly a
threat they would take care of them
but they let him pass on and end up by
him in the end anyway so that was really
just
unbelievable to me i was gonna give this
show a seven after watching it but then
thinking about it more and reading more
about it
and stuff i didn't even catch that was
pretty bad they kind of snuck on you i'm
gonna give it a 6.5 i think this show
would have been great if it was set up
for a bunch of seasons that they didn't
have a finale like they did
and just continued the stories because
they were doing a lot of setup
and then they had to quickly rush in and
end it and have disappointings because
of that
why would you make it a limited series
then didn't feel like a limited series
story or concept
maybe it would have made more sense for
the all-female town of lebel
to work if there's more seasons where
you kind of tease about them and then we
see them getting trained with guns
and them kind of taking over and ending
frank griffin eventually by them
i think that would be more effective and
less predictable but it's still worth
the watch if you love westerns if you
love how it looks
some good story here this is really good
shots a lot of good acting too but
overall 6.5 for me please let me know
down below what you thought of the show
i respond to everybody i want to know if
you liked it didn't like it let me have
it
and please subscribe i review a bunch of
tv shows
movies celebrity interviews trailer
reactions you name it you'll be happy
you did
keep coming back and follow me at
steven1 on twitter and instagram